robbing China go to war on social media
meanwhile the j-rod fireworks you didn't
see Plus Celine Dion in her birthday
suit now you see what happens when we
are gone for an extended weekend all of
the things hey friends this is the daily
Denny I'm Denny director and can you
believe it's already Wednesday I love
America I hope you are recovering well
from the long holiday weekend because
some stars wasted no time this week
stirring up some drama I'm talking about
on-again off-again couple Rob Kardashian
and blac Chyna watching their saga play
out has been kind of sad and on
Wednesday the two went on some pretty
shocking rant against each other so
savage that Rob was sharing naked photos
of who he alleges to be China he first
shared this video of China kissing
another man claiming she texted him that
on the 4th of July but let me tell you
that was just the tip of the iceberg
because in post after post Rob said
China was cheating on him that he'd
always been loyal to her and then
accused her of using drugs he repeatedly
claimed that he paid for her rent and
cars and said he's bought her thousands
of dollars worth of jewelry and even
surgeries now while all of this is going
down China's nude photos were removed
and it's unclear if Rob or Instagram
took them down but then he reloaded them
multiple times China of course fired
back on snapchat with claims of her own
saying Rob slept with other women and
accused him of abuse quote you beat me
up and I'm supposed to be quiet because
you're a Kardashian she then deleted the
snaps and let's just say Rob is showing
no signs of backing down in fact he says
he's got receipts for days
backing up his claims today he posted
this Beyonce mean with the caption my
beyonce lemonade album about to be fired
I can't not and while we've been
recording this episode you guys robbed
instagram has been shut down and now
he's moved the rampage over to Twitter
what's next Rob Facebook live playlist
on Spotify I don't know but we'll be
watching I in another post Rob also
referenced his little sis Kylie Jenner
who dated Chyna's ex-fiance and baby
daddy Tyga
Rob claims China only had a daughter
with him out of spite not love because
she was mad his little sister took her
baby daddy well listen it's been months
since Kylie and Tyga split and it looks
like the mini mogul is moving on because
she just tweaked her key for tiger
tattoo we have the altered ink over at
et online.com all right but moving on
because it is Wednesday and help you get
through the middle of the week and over
this Kardashian drums
I've got your first-ever hump day treat
Chancellor rapper just surprised the
staff at NPR sitting in for a tiny desk
concert backed by a three-piece band and
backup singers it's that classic soulful
chance we know and love
only this time he also covered Stevie
Wonder's they won't go and I go take a
look
big men feelings oh sweet one standing
tall I will watch them fall
[Music]
ah
[Music]
come on chances Stevie tell me you
didn't get chills watching that all
right speaking of the fireworks last
night weren't the only thing that were
lit on Independence Day Jennifer Lopez
electrified the annual Macy's fourth of
July fireworks spectacular last night
where she debuted her new Spanish single
Antonio
ah that's a firetrap Jenny alright but
can we talk about her stage look
Jennifer slays me every damn time and
she really turned it out in this one
rocking this daring black cutout dress
that cost wait for it $22,500 but it's
what you didn't see during her Macy's
performance that's got us talking
it's her Macky with a rod the two are
all smiles and yes locking lips look he
can't even take his eyes off of Earth
kind of creepy hey Ron I'm not sure if
it's a baseball thing burn hey I'll go
for it and clearly alex is also a JLo
fanboy like the rest of us
he was snapped probably taking pictures
of his ladylove during the performance
speaking of pictures we got to talk
about Celine Dion she is literally
turning the streets of Paris into her
own runway but it's for lack of clothes
in a new photo shoot that's really got
us turning our heads the 49 year old
stripped down wearing nothing but her
birthday suit the photo was taken and
posted by Vogue magazine while Celine
was changing her look between fashion
shows Celine spent the day with the
fashion mag attending shows for Paris
Couture Fashion Week and looking like a
boss in the process the proof is in this
mustard tunic and skirt by Dior she wore
in route to the designer show and then
there's this sparkly number where Queen
Celine is literally draped in Swarovski
crystals and getting her life on a Paris
balcony in fact she not only caught a
fashion frenzy from this shot Celine
also had a famous fan in the street when
she posed for that photo and it's Katie
friggin Perry Celine Dion and Paris on a
balcony yes Oh work that leg work that
leg yes good yeah Katy Perry seen Celine
Dion in public is all of us seeing
Celine Dion in public we have all of
Celine's books during Paris Fashion Week
over at et online.com and of course hit
subscribe on e t--'s youtube channels
you don't want to miss another episode
of daily Deni
until tomorrow guys I'm a dance my way
out of here cause it's the real deal